chair we're now live on youtube
thank you good morning and welcome to
team ridge district council's virtual
planning committee on tuesday the 16th
of march 2021 i'm your chair
mike haynes all participants here today
are taking part remotely
and the committee is being viewed online
and recorded
so please bear this in mind throughout
the meeting
in the event of a break in the internet
connection or a power cut
please bear with us as we try to
reconnect
if we are not able to reconnect after 15
minutes
the meeting will be adjourned and
reconvened at a later date
please check the committee page on our
website for further details
please make sure all microphones are
muted when you are not speaking
to avoid any background noise levels
please keep your point
short and do not interrupt when someone
is speaking
if you wish to comment please raise your
electronic
hand and wait to be called
all councillors have been sent the
agenda for today's meeting
any members of the public who want to
view the agenda
can do so by visiting our website
teamridge.gov dot
uk i will now start with committee by
doing a roll call of everyone here
present
when you hear your name please confirm
by saying president
chris can you do that please thank you
chair
um councillor janet bradford president
council development councillor clarence
present councillor colclough
present councillor hayes
president counselor hook
present counselor jeffrey
councillor mcgregor
present counselor nuttall
present councillor nutley present
councillor patch president
councillor parker present
councillor hawking president
councillor goodman bradbury
present and councillor haynes
present okay can i just introduce now
the officers who are with us today
first of all ros eastman who's the
business manager
steve hobbs enforcement officer chris
morgan
democratic services pete
paul woodhead legal officer
okay uh item one on the agenda apologies
for abstinence please chris
uh apologies from councillor cox and
councillor kurzweil and councillor eden
and council hawking is substituting for
councillor eden thank you
item two minutes of the last meeting
these have been
circulated now is it your wish that
those assigned as a correct record
that's been moved by councilman nutley
secretary councillor
parker um can i ask for a show of hands
then please for those
show thank you okay
anyone against no
thank you so that's carried so that was
item
two item three declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
i'm seeing some hands up so the order
that um
they're on the council in that lane
so thank you chair yeah um obviously on
the ashburton 20 stroke
zero zero three seven five stroke major
um in knowing the applicant on this one
but also to note
uh because i'm on both the dartmouth
national park and
team bridge planning i take no part in
the ashburton planning
committee at all okay thank you
so so i'll take it you you will still be
speaking and voting on that one
if i made you yes thank you yeah that's
right i needed to check because i think
i might be calling you first
okay thank you
looks like you're a frozen chair no no
me
um um okay
counselor patch i thought i called you
i'll just check i've got yeah there's
one switched on
sorry i'll just pop in i may not have
done it
temporary sorry about that counselor
patch i did ask
you yeah thank you jay just regarding
item 6a
ashburton as well i i know the applicant
and so what will not participate
or vote on that application okay thank
you
right um i don't think anyone else has
indicated
that um that they wish to declare an
interest
so i'll just lower your hand there
council patch and put it up again
right okay um so that's item
three item four i don't have any
announcements other than i'd note that
councillor connect has um
requested to speak on two items today so
he's joined us and i'll invite him to
speak when we come to those items
item five public participation
we have no public speakers today
so that takes us on to item six which is
the
applications for consideration uh the
first of those
uh six a higher meat farm ashburton
um if i could hand over then please to
ross eastman
to take us through the presentation on
that
thank you chad um just bear with me
while i shoot
okay
let me just switch my displays over hold
on
uh counselor patch i've got you on my
screen at the moment can you put
yourself on the
place
okay here we are uh then
thank you chair um uh this application
is before us today
uh as a consequence of the fact that the
applicant is related to a member of the
council
and the application seeks permission for
um
storage of caravans motorhomes
and boats and other similar items on an
area of land
um close to the parker's farm caravan
site on
uh in an out in an open countryside
location
um the uh plan here shows the entire
extent of the site so you'll see from an
aerial photo shortly uh that only half
of the site at the point the area was
taken
um had been a hard surface to date but
this is the the ultimate plan for the
site
and the land edged in blue is also owned
by the applicant and
is an existing storage area and just to
the south is the parker's farm caravan
site
so here's the aerial photograph and in
this you can see to the bottom of the
photograph the
terraces for the caravan um site at
parker's farm
and you can also see the the dropped
pins
uh on the google map from mead garage
and mead storage um and then at the
the top of the image you've got the a38
uh the the dual carriageway and we
are here just uh southwest of the
junction with the a383 the
ashburton road out of newton abbott onto
the a38 this so this is
uh cayton cross just off the picture
just off the picture um so the site does
have some fairly substantial natural
boundary treatments um
to some of its edges and it has
gates signage fencing and cctv
in place already so the application is
uh retrospective
so these are photos taken by my officer
when they
undertook their site visit um which i
think was
probably during last summer looking at
the amount of
vegetation that is on site in these
images
so the application is recommended for
approval
there are a couple of um conditions uh
as part of that
relating to the landscape treatment and
the type of lighting that will be shown
and just go back to that final image
i clicked off that one too quickly but
this is a street view image from
summer 2019 looking towards the site you
can see the parker's farm caravan site
stretching back up the hill but you can
also see the extent of the screening the
vegetation
when viewing the site from the a38 so
given that this is an expansion of an
existing storage facility
and the limited harm that would accrue
um to the open countryside
the recommendation from my team for me
is one of
approval thank you chat
okay thank you all right um councillor
nutley
uh board member
thank you chair um yes i mean having had
a caravan myself
a few years back um obviously places
like this was always a need for a
storage of caravans
and obviously as things go at the moment
people are tending to go this way for
caravanning and i think that will
increase
to have sites like this is very welcome
and in much need
otherwise people would be having to try
and park them in their drives and all
the rest of it
um as roz was saying it's well screened
from the
a38 and i i see no reason and if i may i
would like to
approve our set out chair okay so you're
moving the recommendations set out is
that seconded
by anyone and girls counselor parker
no relation and raised his hand
okay does anyone else wish to speak
i certainly don't have um any issues
with this one and i'm
content with the officer recommendation
nobody else has indicated they wish to
speak
so in that case then can i ask chris
to go through a role called vote please
and we're voting on
the recommendation as set out that is
um that permission be granted so
it's a straightforward for against um
approval
okay so it's been moved four chris
okay thanks chair um councillor bradford
four councillor bullavent
ball councillor clarence
port councillor cochlear
bull councillor hayes
councillor hook
councillor jeffrey councillor mcgregor
four councillor nuttall
four natalie
four councillor parker
four councillor goodman bradbury
four and councillor hens
that's unanimous chair thank you so
that's been approved
and set out right moving here i didn't
have a vote
oh thank you thanks for hawking yeah
they're gone
chris uh yeah i'm four anyway absolutely
yeah okay that's nothing is four as well
you could add that please right thank
you
so it's unanimous right
moving on then to the next item which is
uh 6b
uh enforcement item on the orangery
um steve are you taking us through that
one
yeah i think so yeah i'll try to um
can you can you turn up your volume
slightly steve
or have you got your microphone in the
right place
it should be the right place can nobody
hear me yeah that's all right yeah
yeah do you hear me now is that better
yeah okay sorry i'll just try and get a
presentation upset
i'm new to this that's okay i can see
the image
this is the image coming outside
right and yeah orange reg at mum heads
is
part of the old there's the original mum
head house and part of the estate and
it's a separately owned note
they're known of the orangey which
contains sort of parkland
and uh sort of residential just
sort of
this is an indication um of where we are
the main mum had houses at the top here
um
and then here's the land owned by the
orangery the site
access is off the sort of back roads
here
with uh the residential property of
dawlish lodge at the entrance here
um an aerial photograph sets out a bit
more of where we are so
here's the residential property up here
and
this is the parkland that's used
this uses part of the um business um
that's the entrance to it and we've had
issues with gates in the past which have
all been removed now
the existing signage has changed um to
what's there now it was a much bigger
one that was more
um inappropriate
and here's some of the um
sculptures around the site um basically
following the complaints about the use
of the property and we carried out an
initial investigation
to try and find exactly what was
happening um it appears that
we're not disputing there is a business
of sorts that runs from there but
um for us to take action we have to have
a level of
quite substantial level to say there's
been a change of use
um in this instance to help with that we
served what we call a planning
contravention notice which is a
legal documents that ask questions about
what activities are being carried out
what the numbers are and things like
which is what's formed basis of our
reports
and from that information although there
are activities occurring
they weren't at a level that constitute
a change for which enforcement action
could be taken
um i appreciate at the moment with the
current lock down situation
there shouldn't be anything going on
there anyway and but there has been
brought to our attention that
there is a lot more activity proposed
once this lockdown's finished so
um i think it's something that would be
looked at more once the lockdown's
finished to see what those levels are
which is why i sort of come up with a
revised recommendation
at the moment for is that we take no
further action at the moment
but it's clear from the campaign the
company's website that there is to be a
an increase
in level activities so we could suggest
now
request the planning application based
on that those details
and we can assess that for the frequency
and scale of the activities
if no application is received within
four months then
we could serve another planning
contravention notice just certainly
actual levels uh
occurring at that time because hopefully
would have be out of the lock down
more today today activities what's going
on and then depending on the outcome of
that
we could take action if um clearly there
has been an increase
and a change of use that's occurring
okay so that's a revised recommendation
but that's
that's my part thank you when would that
four months
actually um start from because i mean
clearly it is all dependent on when
lockdown
sort of completely lifts i presume well
i would
you know clearly they've got a business
plan they've got stuff on the website
that um
indicates what they're proposing to do
so i think we could use based on that
information we could request a planning
application
you know write to them now um after the
next few days
um based on that and then if nothing
comes forth
then we say serve another planning
contravention notice hopefully we out of
lockdown
would get an idea of what the levels are
maybe get some more information from
local residents who could
give us an idea of numbers that are
coming and going and we could put that
together and
have more information and more evidence
to substantiate taking enforcement
action
okay thank you all right if i may
um my my understanding of the current um
plans for
for releasing lockdown is that gardens
like this may be able to reopen from mid
april
so we were thinking that that would
provide potentially provide data for
april may
june type time maybe july before we
serve a planning contravention notice so
we will be well into
this summer season to get a level of an
idea of the level of use that is
occurring at the site
so that we can if an application isn't
forthcoming
we will have covered a substantial
period of time when the property will be
open
as part of our evidence collecting for
this next stage
so we observe a planning contravention
notice there's ordinarily a three-week
period for returning that
so we would hope that by mid-september
we would be in a position
either where we've got a planning
application that we're well on the way
to determining
or that we've got enough information
from a planning contravention notice
and we would serve over the summer that
we'd be able to make a decision
at that point as to whether or not the
level of use at the site had increased
such that uh we consider at that point
that a change of use had occurred
so it's a it's a twin track process from
here moving forward
it's never been our intention that we
would um completely stop looking at what
was happening at the site it's just that
at the moment there isn't the evidence
available to support um any formal
enforcement action
right now okay okay can we
go back to the um normal screen now
please
okay thank you all right right so the
presentation finished um councillor
connect your award member and you've
requested
to speak so um all right
if you'd like to speak now please uh
thank you very much chairman for the
benefit of the uh
recording it's alan collett i'm the
local councillor for the kentucky style
crosswalk which includes
uh man head uh chairman of colleagues
thank you for considering what i sent
uh and also for your understanding of
the concerns and representations
submitted to you by residents in
manhattan i've not
been previously made aware of the
revised recommendation to committee but
i will
update what i'm about to say to you in
light of them
you may also have heard about various
issues of good neighboriness
and legal issues uh in manhattan and
these are not matches for today and i
i won't be covering them in what i'm
saying chairman i want to focus my
comments particularly to the
enforcement matters um we should be
concerned by the creation of the demon
sculpture park
it is a business or is it a permitted
use
and i'm mindful of the new
recommendation from officers
so i'm sure you'll all be familiar with
the phrase if it waddles like a duck and
it quacks like a duck
and it looks like a duck and it probably
is a duck
and in my view devon's sculpture part
gives all the appearance
of being and acting like a proper
business
there's a website and a range of offers
there's the association with the
separate let's group
uh there's on-site catering gift
vouchers available there are retreats
and residentials
and you can join online from three to
ten pounds a month
these are not things which happen for a
small
garden opening 28 days a year under
permitted use
the officer report refers to the view of
english heritage in devon county
accounts
suggesting that they're not concerned
but i haven't seen the questions and i
haven't seen the answers um
and highways have certainly been
concerned on other applications
within the manhattan area and you'll
have had a note of that
in relation to the old telephone
exchange or more recently
for the brick house vineyard application
to become a wedding venue
and so chairman there are real concerns
about
the use of enlisted parkland and indeed
traffic within the
manhattan area
one resident has also told me that you
know they see
the devil's sculpture part is a business
and from where they live when they're in
their garden they're often stopped by
uh cars passing to ask directions to the
uh devon sculpture park
my view colleagues
in light of the new recommendation
is that it is right and proper to ask
for
a planning application and i looked at
the cambridge local plan
to see what it might have to say and
section or
policy s12 deals with tourism and
paragraph c in that chairman says new
tourist attractions in locations where
the scale of visitor and employee trips
is commensurate
with the public transport cycling and
walking accessibility
and environmental constraints will be
supported
there is no public transport in
manhattan and if any of you have cycled
at manhattan
you'll know it's not particularly
cyclable either and paragraph e then
says
increased visitors to heritage and
nature conservation assets where this
maintains
and enhances the quality of the assets
and supports environmental enhancements
for european protected sites any
proposals that may lead to
likely significant infect effects will
only be permitted where no
adverse effect on the integrity of the
site can be shown
and chairman there is just one more
relevant policy in the local plan which
i think
members should take in mind i'm just
scanning through now too
at the right page for ec12
so just bear with me a moment while i
skip along some pages
to page 47
and i just want to draw members
attention to that policy
too
which as is always aware when you go
back a little bit too far
so ec 12 deals with tourist attractions
and it says to support the sustainable
expansion of the tourism industry
tourist attractions will be acceptable
in principle within or adjoining
settlement limits
elsewhere tourist attractions will be
acceptable in principle where they
when it sets a number of policies expand
or improve the existing tourist
attraction where there isn't one
involve an appropriate conversion or
change of use of permanent
sound constructed buildings anyway then
it goes on and finishes to say
development of tourist attractions will
not be permitted unless and
until a satisfactory scheme has been
submitted
to and agreed by the council to ensure
that the development will not have an
adverse effect on the integrity of a
european
site which of course the accessory is
chairman
uh i wanted to speak to oppose the
original recommendation
i'm grateful for offices to for their
new and revised
recommendation and i think in the
circumstances where on the committee
i think i would support it too provided
that there is
an intention to deliver it because
uh chairman i have to say rather sadly
this is an eleventh hour change of the
recommendation
which could have been offered and done
three four months ago and we would have
been further down the road
and we could have reassured the
residents of manhattan uh that team
bridge district council really does
understand the concerns they've had
thank you very much for your time and
consideration chairman comments
thank you councillor
thank you chair um yeah again i wasn't
aware of the
revised recommendations so um i was
going to speak in relation to the
recommendations set out which i
still will do but obviously um throw in
a few
comments related to the revised
recommendation
um my personal feeling was that the
report that we were given
actually summed up the issues that we
need to consider
very well so the key point um from a
planning
point of view in the planning
legislation is that you are entitled to
operate
a business from your home and we'll all
know of
numerous examples in the average housing
estate where people are running
businesses
whether that's a child minders or you
know a huge increase in the number of
food catering businesses run from
residential properties
all of which are um permitted without
applying for planning permission
that is subject to there not being any
material
impact on the surrounding area and
nearby residential properties and that
is the
hurdle that we need to look at with
regard to this
so the first consideration is whether
there has been a material impact
of the operation of this business which
nobody disputes there is a business
operating from there you can see the
website etc etc
um so i don't think anybody's disputing
that it's whether there has been a
material impact
of that on residents um living
nearby in reality there's there's not
many residents that live nearby there's
the
occupier of dawlish lodge um uh
relatively nearby but that's it really
so material impacts are things such as
damaging a neighbour's property
or the in or their enjoyment of their
property
but if a property remains predominantly
in a residential
use and does not affect the amenities of
neighbors
in any material manner then plan
information is not required for that
business activity
so material impacts include things like
the level of traffic or parking in an
area
where it says residential area it's not
one um
unusual activities for a residential
area or if it operates at unreasonable
hours or creates nuisance such as noise
and smells
now out of those the only one i could
pick out as being relevant here would be
the
uh potential increase in traffic that
might
occur as a result of this business um
i should add at this point that i have
been to the orangery so i was invited
there in my role
as executive member for climate change
to look at what the owner is doing there
in relation to
um so i can confirm that the danes are
exceptionally narrow i don't think i
approached him quite the best way
um so really did get caught up in some
very narrow lanes
and i absolutely would agree that they
couldn't take a significant increase
in traffic so i would definitely agree
with that observation
however having been to the site i can
see nowhere in the site
um where a large number of cars could
park um and you can see that from the
aerial photo
so um the the parking area you couldn't
even call it a car park
couldn't take more than ten cars it's a
very rough um
sort of parking area with slope inside
i wouldn't say a maximum of 10 cars so
unless um
they were going to increase the parking
area
of which of course they would need to
apply for plan information anyway
i cannot see any um
increased level of traffic that could
result from that level of
that size of a parking area so in a
sense it's irrelevant what the website
says
they couldn't do any other than small
scale activities at the moment
um and my understanding is that is that
is all they are planning but of course
you know i can't based on my
understanding of the situation
um i visited in
august last year and i can only say that
my observation
as i was shown around the entire well
not the entire state about half of the
estate
was that um it's entirely looks like a
residential property nothing would lead
me to believe that there's other
than a residential property i say one
this small parking area which wouldn't
be an exceptional size parking area for
an estate of that size um
no signage anywhere no no nothing just
really like a large
residential estate uh nothing more than
that
um there wasn't a cafe there were no
signs
there were two other people on site at
the time who i understand where
volunteers
helped him with the garden um so i
accept that post lock down and obviously
looking at their website
there is a potential for an increase in
activity but as i say the parking area
wouldn't
um as it currently is wouldn't allow for
a big increase
in traffic um so you know my conclusion
was that there
there can't uh be a current
um material change of use that can be
evidenced
and if that isn't happening at the
moment then there really is no
justification as it's outlined in the
report to ask for a plan application
when there is no
visible change of use at this point in
time
um the predominant use remains
residential
and i can't see personally how the
neighbors have been materially
impacted in terms of any sculptures on
the site i mean they're
very small within that really large
landscape we're talking small sculptures
within a very very large
landscape um and i i don't think we're
we should be looking at potential future
impacts in the sense that anything that
they did there would need a larger
parking area and they would therefore
need to apply for plan information for
that anyway
so even the revised recommendation
i'm not clear on the justification even
for asking for a planning application
now i would suggest that
what we should be doing is monitoring
the level of activity like i said i
can't see how the activity level can
increase
to a state where it's impacting on the
neighbors in terms of traffic
but um so you know i'm
i certainly didn't think any enforcement
action should be taken
and i'm not even sure whether it's
justified asking for a planning
application at this point because there
is no evidence
change of use i mean you know to be fair
anybody could
have a website where they try and
encourage a business that doesn't mean
to say it's going to be successful does
it that doesn't mean to say you're going
to get lots of visitors
and i can't see how they can accommodate
lots of visitors anyway
so um you know
my feeling is that we shouldn't even be
asking for a planning application we
shouldn't
be asked um asking for enforcement
action
and i don't believe we should be asking
for a plan application even
so i i personally would stick with the
original
recommendation thank you
right if i could just clarify the
position then the original
recommendation was that no
enforcement action is taken at the
current
time as such the um revised
recommendation is not inconsistent with
that because clearly it's saying
that there isn't any enforcement action
taken at the current time
the problem is of course that whilst
it's been said that this is the business
that's going to happen after lockdown
there isn't any evidence of the numbers
at the moment
um which would enable enforcement action
to take place which is obviously itself
uh in agreement with what councillor
hook's just been saying
they can be invited to submit a planning
application they may
decide not to submit it which is
entirely their choice
if they wish to submit one then then
that would clarify
the position such as parking as was just
outlined
if they don't submit a planning
application then the new recommendation
would be that
after four months then the further
planning contravention notice would be
served
on the expectation that there will have
been uh
business taking place uh in the period
once lockdown is lifted
so i'm entirely comfortable with the new
recommendation
in as much as it gives us a bit more of
the picture than just having the
previous one that no
action is taken at the present at the
current time
so it allows members to understand and
indeed for the
um business operators themselves to know
where this council expects to be by the
end of the summer
um so can i just come back then
i'm very briefly as i went over a number
of points repeatedly just okay no no i
just wanted to say that i
actually agree with what you if they're
only going to be invited then that's
perfectly fine
if they're invited to submit a planning
application um
and then we monitor again in four four
months we should be monitoring anyway so
so that's fine with me and i'm happy to
propose the um revised recommendation
thank you
well we can never make anyone put in an
application
i'd second your proposal of the revised
recommendation right i've got two other
speakers now councillor mcgregor
thank you chair um i i
reflect on a lot of the the information
and and communication that's come in
to the to the the council um
particularly to the planning committee
members and and i i take on board a lot
of what
uh both council hook and and councillor
connor have
stated across the the uh the time that
we've dealt with this so far
my concern relies on on basically what
we're proposing in effect
is to assess a period when
we're expecting an increased location
staycation basis
for holiday taking in the uk
particularly into devon
um using a you know people will be
coming to to look at various uh
attractions
and as as councillor conor pointed out
if it looks like a business and it
it it's advertised like a business and
it probably is a business
now what that immediately raises the
question of is the loss of immunity
because we are talking a lot of
immediately specifically
on one of the other neighbors in the
fact that the land
that's used to access the devon
sculpture park is owned by
a neighbor so there's going to be
increased traffic going across that
potentially
and into across their property
which then you know increases wear and
tear it increases the requirement for
maintenance because it is their own land
so you you then you then start to
question is are we prepared as a council
to put
that responsibility onto a neighbor
who has you know an agreement with the
owner of the orangery
that they can access for personal use
and they can access
friends and and and family but you know
and any contractors that are coming in
to
you know to to do a bit of maintenance
but not really for a huge swathe of
potential visitors
that we might be expecting down to devon
so my question would be
is is it appropriate for us not to just
ask them immediately for the planning
application
and to to get that done and not to wait
until we've actually got
neighbors being inconvenienced and lost
and losing amenity
uh across mam head so i i would i would
i would say that in terms of
um recommendation i'd be looking for a
recommendation and enforcement action
to take place now and asking for that
planning application
now as opposed to waiting for four
months to see what impact
is going to be on the neighbors and then
in the local community and i think it's
it's only fair on the local community
and only fair on the on the neighbors
that we do so
yeah the the issue would be though if we
were to serve an enforcement notice and
we don't have the evidence i believe to
serve it at the moment
they could repeal against that and would
continue throughout this summer
whatever happened because if there's an
appeal pending then they could still
carry on
as they were intending to do at the end
of the day we need to have the evidence
before we decide
what to do and to serve enforcement now
without the evidence i think would be
premature on our part and it wouldn't
make any difference to
the use that might happen this summer
anyway
does that answer your question thank you
councillor hawking
thank you um i was going to say exactly
what uh council mcgregor
has said um although i understand
and accept the answer you've just given
my problem with all of this and i i
don't know the area i don't know
um what's been going on apart from all
the emails obviously that's been sent
around
but obviously and i'll be corrected if
i'm wrong
uh obviously this the owner has bought
this property
in some sort of view of of using it
um he's obviously set up a website which
is not
which is not cheap and obviously that
makes there is a commitment there
by setting up this website um
he is not put in planning epic put in a
planning application
to do what he wants to do therefore
i am not convinced in my mind that
um going on what council hook said that
there is no
he would put in a planning application
for car parking i'm not convinced of
mine one that
he would do that or she would do that
sorry or
correction i'm not sure whether he or
she um they would do that
um because uh they've not done it so far
they've not put
application in so far um so they would
just probably carry on
in my view they would just carry on the
way they're going and let things
uh develop as they intend them to
develop
i'm happy with the the recommendation
that's just been given to us um i think
it is important that we have the fact
that we have the full facts
um but it's also important that we get
some sort of planning application
in because it because we need to be seen
to be uh upholding upholding our own
local plan and if there's parts of the
local plan which is not
being adhered to then we need to be seen
to be uh
enforcing that plan um
so in my way that i would love to see
and i understand why we can't but i'd
love to see a plan
application come in now and some sort of
enforcement
being taken um but i accept what you
said
mr german um and therefore it just drops
us back to the revised
uh suggestion that's been put forward by
the officer that we
um asked for a pla ask for a plan
application and monitor over the four
months
um so if that's going to carry if that's
the
the um proposal then fine um
if it's an amendment to the proposal
then we up i'll have to rethink
on our thank you okay councilman natalie
thank you chair yeah i have to somewhat
agree with uh councillor mcgregor and
chandra hawking
um obviously parking and and the traffic
going into that area is going to be a
big issue
obviously seeing the photographs that
our enforcement officer steve
presented this morning and seeing
further photographs this morning
of more artwork in
of the human form i feel that
i would like to think that we could uh
obviously i think a planning application
needs to come in
uh forth with and i would like to think
that we can
enforce the owner not to continue with
any further
development on that site until an
application has been
in and even whether it's been granted
approved or refused
so i would like to see the enforcement
go ahead and as i say if we can
uh object to him continuing with any
more further work i would like that to
be done please thank you
thank you i think whilst many of us
might agree with
your sentiment there i think the way the
system works would mitigate against that
we can't
we can't actually do things until such
time as
legal processes have been gone through
so it's always
up to the individual whether they submit
applications
and if they do something that requires
permission we have to go through the
process
so that we can't jump that far ahead
councillor hook did you wish to come
back again
yeah thanks just to go over some of the
points that have been made in terms of
the access road
um to the orangery um my understanding
is that is a private road that's
only um for for their youth um
and any of their visitors and also for
visitors to the church
who um some sort of covenant or
something has been arranged to allow
people to visit the church which isn't
on their land
um and that road is the access point but
those are the only people that would be
using that um very tiny tiny narrow
lane and then obviously the only person
that um would be
affected by the traffic is the resident
of dawlish lodge right at the entrance
um to the site so just to clear that out
um and and just to go over these points
at the game that i made that
nobody disputes there's a business
operating from there but
the activity level at the moment is not
um as
of a nature that causes a material
change of use that would require
planning permission
so it's really important in my mind to
remember that
because at the moment the the person um
that owns the orangery is not required
to submit a planning application because
there's nothing happening there
that that is a material change of use
that would require it
so it's really important to bear that in
mind we can see a website
that is um advertising um visits
and if those visits happen in a
substantial number
potentially something would require
planning permission
we don't know if that's going to happen
yet and my knowledge of the site having
been there
is that it couldn't possibly accommodate
a large number of visitors
it would be impossible so you know
that's what we need to bear in mind is
i don't see a problem with inviting the
person to
submit a planning application um
if they don't i think we'll have trouble
justifying enforcement action against
something
that isn't happening yet and in my
knowledge of the site
couldn't possibly happen in the in in
the volume of activity to cause a
material change of use
so okay well you're repeating the points
and i think
time time will tell on that and that's
what we're gonna have to
wait and say okay councillor bradford
thank you um i've had
so many emails from residents
in mumhead um who are very very
concerned
and you've only got to go on to the
facebook page
of the devon sculpture park and and i
could
now um sign up to go on a safari
um i feel very concerned about the
wildlife
um you know no planning applications
being
put in um nobody's checking it
to make sure it's all okay
that's my view on it okay thank you
right nobody else is indicated to speak
um was that a hand i was at the sun
jackie you're trying to keep away from
you
um okay um can i ask uh
steve i was gonna say we're not talking
um
you know uh east african safari here
we're talking um
uh presumably looking at the existing
wildlife which
as to my knowledge and of what's gone on
there
is that the wildlife of the area has
increased tremendously which obviously
is the objective of what they're doing
there
so we're talking about a biodiversity
haven here
um not um safari animals as such
yeah okay i don't think we need to get
onto those wider issues i think we'll
stick with
um obviously what we've got currently
happening or
in the future um rosa or speeding did
you want to come back at all with
anything
no all okay um right yes hi thanks
okay um in that case members we've got
the
um can you put it up up on the screen to
remind us please
steve or roz the revised recommendation
which we're going to vote on in a moment
because that's been
proposed and seconded
okay so the planning application has
been requested not
um any stronger than that and if not
then
four months uh a contravention notice
served again
to ascertain the activity levels plus
there will of course have been
monitoring that um local residents may
wish to submit as well
okay so that's the recommendation before
us um
if we can go back to the um other screen
again i'll ask chris to go through
the recorded vote please okay so you see
the recommendation that's been moved so
you are for
or against that recommend revised
recommendation
chris thank you chair councillor
bradford
oh council suburban bull
councillor clarence paul councillor
colclough
oh councillor hayes
[Music]
councillor hook oh counselor jeffrey
councillor mcgregor four
council nuttel four councillor nutley
four councillor patch
councillor parker four councillor
hawking
[Music]
uh councillor goodman bradbury four
and councillor haynes that's unanimous
chair okay thank you so that's the
orangery so we'll await um future
developments on that right moving on
then to
item seven on the agenda um and again i
think
um councilman connor has asked to speak
on this when we
members speaking um the consideration of
the paz
mini peer challenge recommendations
members will note that the
recommendation
is that one accept the recommendation
made by person two consider options for
implementation
so what i'll be doing is if we
go through each of the recommendations
then
i'll ask the committee for views
we won't be actually making any changes
ourselves at this point because clearly
some of the issues relate to uh changes
that would have to be made by full
council
but the purpose of this is for uh us as
a committee to give
our views on each of the recommendations
that are
presented to us okay roz
did you want to say anything at this
point
thank you chair um i i'm sure members
have have read the
report that's in front of them um and
remember the the vote that was taken by
fall council but um
just as a recap um the
paths were asked to undertake
what they called their mini peer review
um
to review all relevant matters and
processes relating to the granting of a
specific planning application
and to report its conclusions to the
council so um
that is what we've got in front of us
the conclusions were that there were
five recommendations for
uh improvement and the report that
you've got
does not include any specific
recommendations as the chair has said it
sets out where we are what paths have
had to say
um what some of our nearest neighbors do
and and
also uh where relevant what the local
government association or other best
practice guidance
says so um you know there's a flexible
approach if you like to
each of those um and as the chair said
this is a
an opportunity to to think about how we
can do things uh
differently or or better and either to
be more efficient or
to improve access and so yeah i'm
looking forward to hearing what you've
all got to say thank you thank you
all right uh councillor connect you've
asked to speak as a non-committee member
so i'll
invite you to speak first if you would
please chairman thank you very much i
just wanted to speak to one particular
recommendation it was about
joint officer councillor training i have
been
previously on the planning committee or
i'm not currently a member
and i really do think that would be an
enormous asset to all of us
um i was a bit disappointed to read the
report and simply that it's
coached in terms of well tell us what
you think because i think
time time is being lost and it really
would be good we've got two years left
of this cancelled period
uh and there is so much unplanning in
terms of both understanding some of the
complexities that officers face
but also i i sometimes wonder if count
if officers appreciate what it's like
for
councillors trying to compete um
in responding to residents as well so to
my mind chairman i'd like to see a good
strong and robust
training program for councillors and
officers uh
working together on some of the
complexities and maybe even looking at
some
case studies in cheap it's not
necessarily current ones but maybe some
older ones
where there have been some real
difficulties and finally chairman this
issue that we sometimes hear in planning
committees about
weight weight that is given to a policy
as it emerges until the end of it
how is that balanced it's not like a
scale is it where at a particular point
it has
you know a particular way but people
often refer to that
and it can be confusing about what that
actually means and an appropriate
weight that counselors should give to
someone so i think there is much that
could be done so i
welcome the recommendation but in
particular just wanted to speak to that
one item i really do think we need to
get on uh with a real and robust
programme of
counsellor and officer joint training
thank you
okay thank you and obviously we'll come
to that i intend
if members wish to have some initial
sort of general discussion and fine but
i intend to go through
each of the um issues in turn
um so that we can come to a view on them
um
each separately so i'd be starting off
with the size of the planning committee
and then on to site visits
and so on so that's the intention so
it's structured in that way but i've got
a number of people wishing
to speak so i'll see what they have to
say generally and then
come on to that uh councillor pax you're
down first
thank you chair um yes i do have a
number of concerns regarding
um this report before us but um
before going into those um i just wanted
to
sort of have a pause and offer the
opportunity for any members of the
committee to reflect
as to whether they might have interests
in this item
no interests were declared at the top of
the agenda
but given that the broad remit of the
pas investigation
um looking at all matters to do with
that planning decision
i'd like to just just pause it and um i
don't i do know doing this obviously
something that you would have considered
chair but you were the chair of that
planning meeting
and and so in the sense that this um
the investigation into all aspects of
that um report
and given that the findings of the pas
report have been met with some
contention
particularly with regard to the
treatment of speakers from the public
objectives
um i just wanted to off that off the
opportunity not just yourself but to any
members who might consider that they
might have an interest in this before
you
actually go through um your itemization
of the um
of the the um of the um recommendations
listed
um i i do have views that this report
um ought to be withdrawn but it i'll
leave that to your discretion as to
whether to hear
hear those arguments before um you go
through the reports
or afterwards uh well i'm
slightly puzzled by your comments um
certainly
i noted that it said that i had acted as
chairman in the correct manner so i
wasn't
particularly getting dwelling on that i
was intending to go through the
recommendations in the report which are
the ones i
highlighted in our agenda today the size
of the planning committee site visits
speaking arrangements committee
and the joint member officer training i
just saw it as going through those
points
that's what we're being asked to do give
our views on that
and then any changes we're going to
ultimately go to full council if they
require their approval to change things
it's getting views today
on those um specific points in the
report it's not
um in my mind in any way re-running the
issues of the report the report's been
done
we've all seen it um and that's what
we're doing today did you want to come
back councillor patch
certainly uh of course it's at your
discretion chair um i just wanted to
briefly pause
and raise that issue um with thinking
that it might arise afterwards so i
thought it best to
raise that opportunity now um you know
as i mentioned i do have uh well three
maintenance returns with this
report and i do think that there's an
argument to be made that the um
the report ought to be withdrawn and not
discussed now i'll leave it to your
discretion chair as to whether i raised
that argument now
or after you've outlined the report
well i was just intending to go through
those points as i said
just now in in 1.2 of the agenda
item the size of the planning committee
site visit
speaking arrangements committee and
member officer training
i can't see any reason why we shouldn't
do those
things regardless of the report because
they're all things
that need to be considered as to reasons
why you wish for
the report to be withdrawn i don't see
that that is
our remit as a planning committee we
didn't ask for this it was full
council if full council wishes to have
it withdrawn that's the full council to
decide
as we currently stand that hasn't been
the case and so i intend going through
the items on the agenda if you wish to
say anything about withdrawing it then i
don't
intend to take that now because i don't
see
it's relevant to what we have on the
agenda before us
so i think i've made my position clear
thank you right so you finished speaking
on that does anyone else wish to speak
generally or
or shall we go through the specific
items i see we've still got two hands
raised i've got um council mcgregor next
yeah thanks it was just just to ask if
you're going to go through the
individual recommendations
separately or go through the individual
recommend recommendations
and then take a vape vote on them
collectively
i think since we're not actually
deciding anything here today
we're just having our views as a
committee being sought
to go through each of them individually
so that we can see what the view of the
committee is
on things like the size of the committee
site visit procedures
speaking arrangements and training so
that's that's what we're
hoping to achieve views of the committee
on those items council thank you
yeah just as i understand the report and
she asked
us to accept the recommendations made by
pas
so we are asked to agree something okay
well we can
uh we can talk about that one in a
moment then yeah council bradford
thank you um well
the mini peer review came back with
answers to
completely different questions than we'd
put um
this was for the langford bridge inquiry
um of the seven of the major concerns
that tdc full council
voted to investigate in relation to the
length of bridge planning decision
the pas advised that five of them were
outside their investigation
remit can the planning committee please
consider how
tdc has satisfied itself that the five
items
described by the pas in the report as
very serious
have in any way been dealt with please
well i've got the motion before me that
council agreed and it certainly doesn't
list
seven items it doesn't list any items
the the thing that was resolved
at full council was it says to reassure
elected members in the general public
the individ independent planning
advisory service
is invited by team bridge council to
review all relevant matters and
processes
relating to the granting of application
langford bridge farm
kings coastal road at the planning
committee on the 21st of january and
report its conclusions to the council
so i don't know where these seven points
are i know there are a number of points
in their report
but that's what was asked for by council
a report was produced
and uh within that report there were
some recommendations which we're
considering here
today so that's that's what we intend to
do
coming back to councillor patch's point
about recommendation one
accept the recommendations bypass and
then secondly to consider the options
for implementation
i was obviously uh more intent on
considering the options
so if councillor patch i'll take
recommendation one accepts the
recommendations made by paz
if councillor patch wishes to come back
and um
[Music]
speak to that specific item then we'll
take a vote on
part one which is accept the
recommendations
council patch did you wish to come back
on that
um certainly i'll um
voice my concerns on that matter now
chair
um but i i have actually three um
distinct concerns regarding this report
um with regard to
that that point that you've drawn us
back to i'll just very briefly
whizzed through them um because they all
they are all german and relate to each
other firstly
as has been acknowledged um any changes
to the unprostitution regarding the
planning committee
will need to go to full council so
firstly i'm not sure
why this report is coming to us rather
than full council
secondly um regarding the the
recommendations
that are presented and this item one in
terms of the
the recommendation to accept the
recommendations of the the pas report
i think that this is being presented out
of context
because we don't have the pas report
presented to us
and yet we're being asked to um accept
well scrutinize and um examine consider
those consider
those recommendations but actually
having the report
in which those recommendations were made
i'm not sure why
um we are not being encouraged to look
at that information
um but but thirdly my main concern with
with this report that's before us
not with the pas report but actually
with
the um report um
that's on the agenda is that it's
incoherent
and contradictory so just what i mean by
that
is if we look at um 1.2.1.2 on the
report
which says this report does not provide
a specific recommendation to members at
this point
but rather outlines details for members
in relation to our practice
etc and then we go to the top of the
report on the purpose of report that is
in accord with um
1.2 which says that the purpose of the
report is to provide background
information for members
on our current practice the pas
recommendations and relevant lga advice
and yet the recommendations immediately
follow that recommendation one
is to accept the recommendations made by
pas
so we're simultaneously being told in
this report before us
that we're not being provided with the
recommendations and yet we
we're being it's proposed that we accept
the recommendations of bas
so i see there's an inherent
contradiction in this report
and if it if we were to vote to accept
this report i'm not sure what that would
mean it would be arguable that we're
accepting that there were no
recommendations before us
but at the same time that we agreed to
the recommendations of the pas
so that was my um what that's what's
behind my remark
that this report be withdrawn um failing
it being withdrawn
i would i would make a proposal that
this report is rejected for those three
reasons that
it shouldn't be here it should be full
council that
there's not enough information to
consider it in its real context that is
the pas
report and it is incoherent and
contradictory
okay thank you well i what i would say
is
on page three of the report which
members have all seen
it gives recommendations and there are
the recommendations that are there
those are the recommendations of the paz
report they are
bullet point one review size of planning
committee
two improve arrangements for site visits
three
one team approach and ownership to
planning committee arrangements
four tailor arrangements where necessary
for example speaking arrangements
and finally joint officer accounts for
training to cover
planning political awareness the art of
possible those are the recommendations
of the pas report so the first item that
we're
asked to view here is accept those
recommendations
um and indeed they form the basis of
what we have before us in the office of
report
so i don't find myself in agreement with
what you've just been saying
um right councillor hook
thank you um yeah i i note that the um
an appendices appendix is linked there
is a link to the planning peer challenge
so if
members wanted to read it they could
read it um
themselves beforehand so it is listed
there as a background paper
just as with a planning application you
could go and look at the web
um plan portal and read all sorts of
details about that application which
were presented in the report
so um you know that was available to
read and then this is obviously just
summarizing the recommendations
um but i would agree with the point that
um
you know as as has been outlined today
is about us
discussing our views on those
recommendations and i don't believe it
should be anything more than that so we
just gather
our views here today on those
recommendations those get noted down
um and then obviously where the
decisions made is
is elsewhere at full council etc um so i
i would also agree that we shouldn't
be um you know accepting the
recommendations
as such but just just discussing today
are our views on them
okay thank you councilman
this makes absolutely no sense it was
all about langford bridge um
chair can you show the page please with
the five elements
that were outside their remit and what
has been done to satisfy them
that isn't what we're being asked to do
today if it's outside their remit then
that's what they were saying
was outside the arena we're being asked
to look at the recommendations that they
have made
which are the ones that i just talked
about that's what we're going to do
i don't think any further sort of
obstruction to that is getting us
anywhere
so i i will move on now and i'm not
i mean i'm not going to waste any more
of the committee's time
actually arguing about uh the point one
then to accept the recommendations i
think we'll just go straight on and only
consider
part two which is considered the options
for implementation and the
recommendations because that's
that's basically what we're uh needing
to do so that we can give our views to
full council when
any changes are made so can we move on
please the first item
is the size of the planning committee
would some anyone wish to speak
on the size of the planning committee um
i've got council
clarence who's not spoken yet indicating
speak
uh thank you chairman yes the size of
the planning committee
uh when i originally joined back in 2003
there were some 46 members and the
planning committee was
um consistent of 21 members and it's
largely remained of that size
now the original concept was uh
having it at this size that we could
have
one member from all the single member
wards
actually on planning and and indeed
cover all the other awards as well
with one member that was the size
and i think this has worked particularly
well and even with the now cut down
numbers
there are councillors on this committee
myself for example representing a
one-man ward
council jeffrey councillor mcgregor
councillor patch
we're all on here and we if you like
are able to give our views passionately
about the areas
that we represent and i think this is
what it's about
and i i i can't uh
shall we say um agree to this sort of
um view put forward that we should cut
the numbers down
any more than we have over the past i
like to think that teambridge planning
committee has been a very good
and well-run planning committee uh since
2003
it's been kind compassionate and caring
and it's been
often taking into account individual
circumstances
uh personal situations if you like into
account
and coming i think to the right decision
and it's
uh i would argue that at 17 as we are
now
that we stick with that and never mind
when it comes to size
of what what other planning committees
are doing uh
elsewhere thankfully thank you for the
peer review that some of the other
committees are smaller
but i'd like to think we're doing things
right thank you mr chairman
thank you council mcgregor
i think actually council bulletin was in
front of me but um
not on my screen it's not okay um
yeah i mean in terms of the the um the
numbers
on the planning committee i i do
appreciate you know um
that the the 21 was seen as particularly
high
but effectively what we're looking at is
just over a third of our councillors are
on our planning committee
and how many of those planning
committees are full 17
uh attendees in in any case anyway
um but i think it it's it's good to have
the representation as pointed out by
councillor clarence
uh from single member awards as well as
or you know representation from double
member awards as well
um i'm not really in favor of reducing
it anymore and i've heard
um from uh one of the the members of the
pas committee i was at another meeting
with with that particular person
um yeah at a warwick event
and um some some planning committees are
as low as five
people and effectively what what we're
looking at is a potential for
a lack of scrutiny now it's a point that
council bullivan's brought up in the
past
is that transparency and scrutiny is
is really important and i think our
residents need to feel
the um planning committee is properly
scrutinizing
and probably properly transparent and
having it in a smaller group
may reduce their confidence in our
planning committee
if it is um seen to be more
often rubber stamping through um things
without
major discussions um you know we know
how passionate counselor
patches and also councillor bradford on
on certain particular subjects
and i think it's valuable that we have
as wide a um
[Music]
a series of opinions uh on on planning
applications as we can
thank you thank you councillor bullivant
thank you i think it's important to
remember that
uh team bridge is a diverse um area with
representation from coast country rural
urban
a lot of different districts and
therefore having the views represented
on the committee that covers all of
those things is important
equally it's important to remember that
sitting on this committee we act on
behalf of the 136
000 people of team bridge and not
specifically for the universe of their
local community
my concerns about the number i'm not
particularly concerned about the number
divided it can be structured in such a
way that it's representative of the
whole of the community of team bridge
i believe what we have to be careful of
is that we're looking at a system
which seeks to that doesn't seek i
should say to rubber stamp
the executive decision on a an
application
but it does get the level of scrutiny
and
evaluation that any application deserves
and the people of team beach here
require um
so my concern say not about the number
it's about the structure
and how the decisions of that committee
can be representative
on behalf of 134 000 people thank you
thank you
councillor patch
thank you chad like just like to agree
with um pretty much
all of the comments that have been made
so far um
particularly um councillor clarence's
point about ward member representation
and i'd like to sort of briefly uh make
reference to another of um
councillor clarence's um approaches
where he's been very thorough with um
looking at the i.t um expenditure with
regard to other
um authorities and making comparisons
and
and um in particular i recall looking at
the um
the tables of information that were
presented regarding that and so
looking at the report page 18 on the
um information about number of members
um
overall a number of members on the
planning committee where comparisons
um are made i i i would like to see
some more information put into that
table really so that we can sort of
flesh out um
those comparisons when we're making them
in terms of the number of wards
um the percentage of all members on the
planning committee that that type of
thing
um just i i think if this comes to full
council for a decision it would be good
to have
um a wide-ranging sort of um
quite a thorough investigation of the
numbers um
but that that's on top of my sort of um
sort of feeling that um as as counselor
clarence and others have mentioned
um it feels about right at the moment i
don't think we should be
reducing numbers any further thank you
council conquest
yes uh thank you chairman very simply
um it isn't 12 months since we uh
took this matter on board and reduced
the
planning committee from 21 to 17 it
isn't 12 months
so we've really not given the 17
a trial a proper trial yet we haven't
had it long enough
also we never seem to get a full
attendance so look this morning but we
haven't got 17 members present
so it's very not very often we get the
full 17 here
so we have a limited uh committee
already
so i i really think we should leave well
alone and
try 17 from for longer to give it a fair
trial
uh and perhaps you know i go along with
one member
from each ward i mean that's the way i
would like to see it but obviously
that's not the the what we're discussing
today
thank you yeah
it wouldn't work under the um political
arrangements i'm afraid
okay councillor government bradbury
thank you i just wanted to i mean
some of what uh councillor kolcloff has
just mentioned i i agree with
um but i disagree that that if there's
less members in a
uh planning committee that it means less
scrutiny or attention i mean members are
able to
have their input whether they're a
member of the planning committee or not
they're able to
to speak on an item and read and support
and
um represent their constituents anyway i
i agree that it would be good to see how
are the numbers as we are at the moment
17
um how that beds in and i agree also
that
we're not always getting all members
currently that are coming along to
um committee so anyway just wanted to
make that point
thank you well i'll take a sort of
view on this one then i'll ask i'm
following a couple of speakers i'll
move that we um currently we wish to
stick at 17
and we'll take a vote on that at the
moment i'll see councillor patch wishes
to come back is it
brief it is brief just to come back on a
point from councillor goodman bradbury
i don't think it's enough to say that
ward members or any members can
come and address the committee on
particular applications
because once the debate has started
points are points arise
for debate and that member then is
excluded from taking part
in that debate if they are not a member
of the committee they cannot um rebut
arguments or put forward further points
so
i'd just like to sort of put my point on
that
okay thank you that's everyone that's
indicated they wish to speak now so
i've proposed that
the committee um wishes to stick at 17
given that it's only recently changed to
that and
the number and not everyone always is
able to attend or have substitutes i
think we're two down
today somebody like to second that
yeah okay that's um council cold club
i think originally can we take take a
vote on that please chris
so you're four against seventeen
thank you chair councillor bradford
councillor vote relevant for
councillor clarence four
council of colclough oh
councillor hayes
i think he's outstanding i think he's
left the meeting
councillor mcgregor or
councillor nettle poor
councillor nutley or councillor patch
or councillor parker or
councillor hawking
councillor hawking
yeah uh councillor goodman bradbury
oh and councillor haynes
uh that's unanimous chair okay thank you
if we can move on then to the second
item
[Music]
right um the second item is site
inspections
um now clearly there was some sort of
slightly
more complicated aspects to this
as to what is seen as being appropriate
um at the present time of course we've
not had
um hardly any site inspections because
of the
um the lockdown
we have a smaller committee now 17
previously when the committee was larger
it became more unwieldy and that's why
there were teams
certainly in the days when the committee
was even bigger than the 21
that was seen as appropriate one of the
suggestions now is that
um that all members go to a site
inspection
uh if it's deemed to be necessary uh
currently the arrangement is that all
members are invited to a major
application
and it was our practice to have major
application
site inspections prior to those going to
committee
in order that um there wouldn't be a
delay in the process
because of the obviously the government
um performance targets that we had to
meet
so that's the situation so it is a bit
more complex but our
welcome members views on where they
think we should go with our
uh site visit um policy shall we say
we'd recommend okay i've got councillor
hooked first
thank you yeah i'm in my time on the
planning committee since 2011
i mean we did used to go on many more
site visits um you know cover defied
um than we have done say in the last two
or three years which which i think is
good so it's been about
um there needs to be a good reason to go
on a site visit to establish something
that you couldn't have done
by looking at photos etc committee so
based on
on that i think you know we're doing a
doing site visits where necessary
at the moment so that's fine um in terms
of the number of people
members that manage to get to site
visits my understanding is that
sometimes the figure is very low you
know and members
even on the team that should be going
for one reason or another
can't um attend so i think the idea of
inviting everybody
on the planning committee makes sense um
so that we get a wider
range of views as possible but i
certainly don't think
going on the site visit should um mean
that only those people can make
the decision on the day i mean we need
to be able to trust um the opinions of
our fellow members
a variety of opinions that are then
reported at committee
so i wouldn't make it an essential
requirement but i think it probably
makes sense to invite
everybody um i was going to comment on
the fact that sometimes um
when an application gets delayed for one
reason or another sometimes for many
months
um you're asked as a member oh you know
we have a site visit eight months ago
and suddenly your name's read out and
you think oh gosh you know
not sure i remember what it what i saw
eight months ago
so perhaps there should be a time limit
on um when we're asked to give an
opinion
i mean obviously usually it's literally
the committee that follows
um but maybe there should be a time
limit and then if another site visit is
required then another one takes place so
that we all
refresh our minds um and then
i noticed in the lga um commentary on
this it said that
pratt members ought to be asked to
demonstrate they understand an issue
i thought that was amusing how do we do
that we have a test on it before we
speak on it
or you could have a test on the
knowledge of every application before we
vote on it
um you know it probably makes sense that
we do all understand the issues but i'm
not sure
quite how we go about proving that we
will understand the issues
so um you know those would be my
comments
thank you council bradford
yes i just i wanted to um echo that that
um i think there should be a time limit
on um
when you go on a site visit and when it
comes before the planning
um as with langford bridge there was
quite a serious delay between the site
visit
and when it came to thank planning
thank you councilman patch
yes i'd just like to um second um
councillor hook some points there
uh well but in particular that the issue
of sort of um
demonstrating that issues are understood
on the application
um of course i think we we should expect
that we do all
understand the issues on each
application but seems to get to go into
far too much detail to consider making
recommendations
that they demonstrate they understand
and understood the issues
um of the site visits uh it just seems
to me this recommendation
they've gone into a lot of detail in
exploring this issue
perhaps to compensate for the fact that
some other issues put before them they
chose not to investigate
one of things because this issue was
within their remit of what they could
comment on
okay i think we're getting an agreement
on our council called if you want to
come in
yeah yes just simply determined to say i
agree
uh with a lot of that's been said but um
i think i agree that all members
should attend the set have the chance to
attend the site inspection but i think
the information and the the photographs
and the diagrams and
that comes up on the screen is so good
now
that is so much better than it used to
be that really
you feel as though you've been anyway
it's
it's so detailed so um i think
site site inspections should be limited
to the absolute
minimum and absolutely when it's totally
necessary
but i think everyone should have a
chance to go
thank you counselor
as i understand it there are two basic
reasons for having a side visit
one is where there's a major application
i need to give members a view of what
the implications of that major
application is but secondly
it's where the committee feels that it
hasn't had enough information provided
through the report to come before the
committee for that those members who
don't know
or can't make a decision based on the
information provided
for them to go out and have a look at
the site um
for that reason i would always say that
the people who go out on the site visit
for that latter
reason should be those people who should
be restricted just to those people who
can't make a decision based on the
information that the
officers have provided
thank you councillor clarence
thank you chairman i think we've got the
balance um about right
um all i would add uh
here is have we got the balance right
for the major applications
and i say that because um perhaps it
uh all members of the planning
committees ought to go to
all major runs and those
are held in the open where people can
come and sit
this was the type of thing that used to
happen when i served on devon county
council planning committee
the issues were big we would go to a
village hall
or something like that where the whole
family would file
whether to win the cleaner notes didn't
i haven't got a window cleaner
um the whole um committee filed in at
devon county council to a village hall
where they're on a where the application
was like
the equivalent of our major ones and
there would be a huge audience there
uh questions would be put for from it
and you can really
gauge the strength of the opinion or not
and what have you so
i think we got it right with the small
ones perhaps we we're not so good with
the major ones
just a point an observation that i'm
making uh
to sort of throw out into the mix of
while we're talking about this
thank you chairman thank you i think the
meeting you referred to the devon county
ones i know i i attended
um meetings such as that in the past but
that was one where they were making a
more formal
recommendation and it was being
discussed you know because of the
size of the county perhaps for people
who wouldn't get to county hall to hear
the planning committee
in its full sitting so and and the
committee isn't
structured like our own um for sort of
as many applications
so personally i wouldn't wish
to go along the model you've just
outlined our model
is that we just go out to see the site
and then all the debate takes place
in the council chamber council mcgregor
uh thank you chair you know i've done a
a couple of site visits and and i found
what we do currently has been quite
favorable really
um it comes down to uh
i think in in some some councillors it's
a level of
you know what's the what's the impact uh
for for the local community for the
individual
planning application and for others
they're quite happy to
um see what's been see what's been seen
and discussed
and then get the report back at the
committee i i would
suggest that the system we have
currently is mostly
um fully serviceable as as a process and
i i quite
i'm quite happy to to retain what we do
currently
thank you council patch
thank you chair yeah i'm just having a
close look at the um on what's
under the headline the pas
recommendation but then it's actually a
suggestion
and the meat of it seems to be that they
suggest a simpler approach is adopted
the clear statement of the issue the
visit is responding to
and short notes the meeting shared very
shortly after i see a problem with this
if um site visits and the reporting back
is to be limited
just to the one issue which was set out
because on the site visit
our members might actually notice other
material considerations that are germane
to the application may wish to raise
those
issues when it comes back to committee
um
and and so i i i'm minded to agree with
councillor mcgregor and others that um
if it ain't broke don't fix it it seems
to work very well at the moment
okay well i wouldn't disagree with that
um it's just a question of whether
everybody who's on the committee gets
the
invite to go to site inspections which
um
i think is is what councillor hook
originally said and i think that was
as a proposal i think that may have been
seconded um
but with a time limit um that they go
back
sort of within a period of time um to
the committee if it's a major that's
been asked for before
um was that a proposal from councillor
hook that you'd sort of said that
everybody should go
um obviously the procedure as as we've
got currently
but with a time limit for majors and i
think
council bradford may have agreed with
that to second that
council and jackie is that um yeah i
didn't mean as a proposal i was just
making comments but i think that was the
main
points i made um i would say also
include minor applications so there are
some times when minor applications get
delayed for
for reasons and then all of a sudden
you're expected to remember a site visit
from
many months ago so you know just uh
time limit on site visits for all
applications okay
okay and i'll second that then if um
members are happy that um they now
understand what is revoking
sorry a statement of what we're actually
voting on what the agreed
wording is um well it isn't
it this isn't actually a decision this
is
our views but i mean as i understood it
it was
that site inspections everyone uh we
wish to see everyone get
um invited to them although clearly it's
not an essential requirement
for you to be able to vote at the next
committee
there's a time limit um but the process
otherwise remains
as we currently have that's why
and i'll see one or two nodding now so
that's why
i would agree agree with that but just
put on record i i'm not necess
issue i think notes are taken and then
the presentations at committee meeting
are of such a quality that we we can be
refreshed
and remember what the issues are so i
would agree
with all the time limit thank you
all right um take a vote on that please
chris okay uh councillor bradford
oh councillor bellevant
councillor clarence four councillor
colclough
councillor hayes
jeffrey councillor mcgregor
four councillor nuttall
four councillor natalie uh
council nutley four councillor patch
or councillor parker or
councillor hawking four
councillor goodman bradbury
and councillor haynes that's unanimous
chair
thank you so we can move on to the
next item which is the public speaking
at
planning committee meetings um
members are familiar with the current
arrangement
with um three minutes for a
for a general application but five
minutes from major
as you can see on the table under 219
it gives the number of objectives and
that we have and the
time that they're permitted to speak um
and ros has kindly given us some other
neighbouring examples to look at there
um personally i
am content with um what we currently do
in comparison to others i see that
east devon does have more objectors
able to speak although only for three
minutes
on um major applications
um are there any views that members wish
to express
councillor councillor hook
thank you yeah um in all my time on
planning committee i've never
never been concerned about the fact that
there are only two speakers on majors
um which i think was what this um was
largely about
um and i said you know it's reassuring
to see that other councils are
approximately
the same um so
yeah i mean you know all of us would
want to be absolutely sure we're hearing
the public voice as much as possible
whenever possible but if you look at the
example this morning with the orangery
and the um the views we had expressed by
email
you know a huge number which you know
we've got there to read and absorb
which is almost better than hearing it
on the day
but um you know on the day as well great
you know but we
have multiple opportunities as well as
looking ourselves at the planning portal
and the comments people are making which
you know
we should do some major application
anyway i certainly do
so i'm happy with um two but you know
equally
i wouldn't be or i wouldn't object to
say three speakers
you know three speakers for four minutes
each i i don't
you know that that's fine as well but
i've never it's never been an issue of
particular
concern to me i do feel i've heard the
public voice on
major applications thank you council
mcgregor
uh thank you chair um yeah i'm in in
similar
vein to council hook i'm i'm
of the opinion that we are not out of
the um
ordinary in terms of the number of
speakers that we have and and the
objectors
um in in terms of the miners
um i do i do think though that what we
perhaps sometimes
um forget is that you know when we have
something like the orangery as
councillor hook puts up and
there was a significant volume of not
only
um you know people communicating to to
members of the committee but also
a huge volume of different concerns as
well
and that can't always be covered in a a
three-minute speech
uh by one objective acting on behalf of
several others
and i think it's it's really um
difficult for some people to express
a community or neighborhood um position
when they're trying to summarize into to
three minutes on a minor
application or even five minutes on a
major application i think
perhaps we should look at the the
numbers of speakers that we do
particularly when um you know you have
a planning officer who's presenting a a
um
planning application to the committee
and could take up to 15 minutes to get
through a planning application
um presentation and then we're expecting
an objector to
to highlight and respond to all the
points that are uh
covered in the application in in five
minutes or or three minutes
and i think it's it's it's telling as
well that
if we only have two people i think
sometimes we
we forget that when we look at the
report and the report comes to
to committee is that whilst officers
have taken account of
various aspects of of of objections
from the many objectives in in some
cases um
a lot of those aren't covered in in the
in the general discussions and i think
sometimes that also prevents um
you know a feeling of equity in terms of
um you know covering the points and
having
actually and this is one of the areas
i'm particularly concerned about
is proper material considerations um
seem seem to to get less consideration
than perhaps they should do like loss of
immunity
loss of privacy etc and sometimes it's
important that objectives get that
opportunity to get that message across
thank you councilman patch
thank you chair um yeah a couple of
points i would raise regarding the
number of speakers
there might there may well be an issue
in limiting the speakers particularly
for major applications
um in a sense that if if there were um a
two
three three four five um important
or potentially important contributors um
several of them are going to be denied
the opportunity to speak and this might
well be the case
um as in fact happened with the
um sort of langford bridge application
which stimulated this
piece of work by the pas that you you
might have a
local sort of bodies such as parish
councils or residence groups
um who are not initially able to um
speak because the places have been
allocated to other speakers
um so joe i would think we ought to give
some consideration
to going beyond two but there's a second
concern
um relates to again so thinking back to
langford bridge
is i i believe that the the people who
are who are being lined up to
speak um for and against applications
um their identity should be made public
um on the agenda
of the uh meeting for each um planning
committee
and the reason i say that is the
unfortunate incident that happened at
langford bridge
um consideration of the um of that
planning application
whereby to unknown to the public
objectors or or um supporters rather no
objectors
i get that right their objectives were
um actually withdrew at the very last
minute
meaning that the bonafide um speakers on
behalf of local residents
had already not had their expert witness
available but they were then at the very
last minute drafted in
um to given the opportunity to speak in
it in an unprepared way
um so i i think not only should we think
about
the the number of speakers allowed for
major applications but also
maybe a bit more transparent in terms of
who is being lined up to speak um
to guard against um the situation that
we had at the langford bridge with the
um
the claim of the so-called ghost
objectors um
who went through at the last minute and
um nobody knows who they were
yeah the the ghost objectives issue
isn't within our sort of remit
to consider today other than the number
of speakers
um all i would say is that um on the day
i was asked if i would allow others to
speak
in place of those who'd withdrawn and
obviously i agreed to that
other than that the issue of naming
people is is i think covered by other
relevant
legislation and it isn't part of our
discussion here today
what we're discussing here today is the
number of speakers coming back to
another point just now about parish
councils
i'm aware of another authority not in
the south west
um well not not in our part of the
southwest that actually
um has parish councils um given the
right to speak
in addition to any other public speakers
who may register to speak so that is
something that
um members may wish to consider that
parish council plus um two
others um if the parish council wish
wish to appear i mean that's that's the
thing that could be considered if
members felt that was a
a useful thought okay i've got um
to others to speak who's next it's
castle bradford please
thank you um i just would
i get confused with all this speaking
thing you know whether you can speak
whether you can't with a
you know who can speak um
so would the council allocate an object
a speaking slot to somebody who had not
objected to a specific application
um the way that it works is published on
the agenda
that any members of the public wishing
to speak have to apply to the committee
section before
a cut-off time registering their um
request to speak at committee that's
that's how the system works
um somebody from the committee section
or legal would would
perhaps best be advised on any questions
that they're asked
i don't know that um
but um i don't know if anyone wishes to
speak on that
is there an officer there that can
answer that chris are you able to or is
it somebody else that
that actually um yeah
i can speak on this um we take
public speakers they email us um
up to two working days before the
meeting requesting to speak
um at the committee um after this
we um usually hold a test meeting with
them to make sure that they're
okay with using zoom obviously this
doesn't apply
to the the application that we're
talking about
today or inspired the paz report um but
at the moment the way it works is that
we accept up to two public speakers for
each side of a major application
um and one and they speak for five
minutes all of them
or we accept one public speaker for each
side of a non-major application
um and they get three minutes to speak
although we also do try to balance out
the time
in order to allow people so if there's
an imbalance of
speaker numbers we try to make sure that
people get the same amount of time to
speak
okay yeah thank you
um what if they hadn't
hadn't objected to that application
beforehand
it doesn't matter we you don't check
there's no cross-checking process
at the moment to see whether or not
anybody has objected already
the way that people find out that
something is going to committee though
would either be
through happening across it on our
website or more likely that they've made
a representation on the application and
so have had some correspondence from
us that's alerted them to the fact that
the application is going to be
considered by committee
um but but no we don't undertake that
that cross-checking exercise
um uh you know no more than we
uh check whether or not the parish
council
have uh taken up its opportunity to to
comment if they were choosing to speak
or or
other parties you know um the officer's
report summarizes all of the
representations received and
all of the representations received are
available on our our
website so they are all taken into
account in the
the um balanced
analysis that's presented by officers
but no we don't go through and we don't
have the resources really to go through
and check whether
a another person has
specifically already made an objection
in relation to
any given application before we register
them
to be able to speak on that particular
application at committee
would you sorry would you allocate an
objective speaking
slot to a person that didn't live in
team bridge
well we we allow people to speak on
either side
obviously we have um planning
consultants
and coming to speak so
normally if you that didn't
live in team bridge and wanted to speak
would you
put them in and and uh allow them to
speak
if they lived outside of this
um nice
i think if there isn't a specific policy
in place on that this is something that
we could recommend
that the council looks at in terms of
where somebody who's who's applying to
speak um
where they are resident i mean that's
the thing to be considered
um i don't think um we can get a clear
answer on that
out of chris at the moment because he
may not always have
been doing that janet is there anything
else you wanted to say sorry cancer
bradford um
no but i'd like an answer sometime yeah
i don't
yeah i don't know if we have an answer
but i think i've taken it up as a point
that has to be considered that should be
considered when
any decisions are made on changes to the
um
procedure for this okay sure if i may
um just just to say there's there's no
um
there's no criteria as to where people
the objectors or supporters can be
anybody there's no criteria that they
have to be resident
or they have to be the applicant or the
object we
we take them as they phone they phone
and register their interests
okay well we need to we can take
that forward as a recommendation if
members are so minded that
the criteria of speaker is is um
considered particularly
in view of the um the ghost uh
speaker that we had previously
that was the subject of part of this
reason for this report
okay um i've got cousin nutley next
please
thank you chair um yes i mean i think
our officers
present very good reports to us and also
i think our website
for further information is on that um i
obviously sit on the dartmouth
park authority planning which all 19
members in actual fact take part in that
and i know we don't wish to extend um
meetings to go on and on um and you did
mention
about paris and town councils
representing
um on the dark national park we do have
the size objectors
and the applicants um we do have you
know
people come from their parish councils
and town councils to actually speak
another thing we do do as well which i
don't think we've ever done on team
bridge
we do allow once the objectors are
spoken or the applicant has spoken
we do the chairman then allows members
to ask that particular objector or the
applicant
various questions now we probably don't
want to go down that way because the
same
it extends but it may be a thought of
doing that it then gives the
you know gives counsellors and the
planning committee
the chance to kind of air some other
views that they may have
and you know obviously ask the objector
why there aren't why they're objecting
against certain things
but that's just the points that we do on
the dartmouth national park chair
thank you um
counselor hook next please
thank you i was going to talk about your
suggestion for allowing the parish
council to speak
um in addition to any public speakers
you had
um and you know it sort of sounds a good
idea
but i would just you know have a few
caveats i mean obviously
a lot of district councillors already
parish or town councils and presumably
would
um avoid the view of the parish or town
although not necessarily because they
might always might speak as an
individual
and that's where the danger comes so if
you did have a parish or town
rep speak you'd have to be certain that
we were speaking on behalf
with the collective view that had
already been established of their parish
or town rather than coming to speak
as another individual necessarily
because then you
could argue that you should just have
another public speaker but with that
caveat i think it
probably sounds like a good idea um
uh i was going to speak on the last
point that was made about
where an objector lives the danger with
that is of course
a group of residents for example that
were objecting to an application or
supporting
might want to um uh ask
a representative of a particular
organization
i'm just sort of thinking maybe an
expert in historic buildings or an
expert on bats or whatever it might be
to come and speak on behalf of that
group and i think this has happened
before for example i think
well the residents group have asked for
example backed
experts to come and speak on behalf of
of their opinion on on an application so
that you know you wouldn't want to limit
those people speaking presumably you
want to hear
very much hear their opinion as experts
on a topic
so that i i don't believe we should do
that i don't believe we should be asking
um why someone has chosen to speak we
there's no evidence i'm aware of that
says that the public speakers we've had
to come to speak
were there for any other than the reason
that they wish to either object to
support that application
in question so those would be my
comments um
you know in terms of what we could
recommend from now on i mean i don't
object to having three speakers you'd
have three speakers at four minutes and
then
an additional parish councillor rap as
long as they
summarize the collective opinions of a
parish opinion
um yeah those are okay
thank you councillor patch
thank you chair um just i'm recalling
the process
um set out um for
allocating speaker slots as i as i
believe it
set out is that if there are more than
two
wanting to speak on a major application
then
um those objectives are encouraged to
agree amongst themselves
who might um best speak at the meeting
um
there's obviously a problem here if i'm
in the case of the ghost objectors there
are people who put their names forward
but don't wish to be identified
to other people as to who they are um
obviously
they would be identified when they come
to speak but then if they decide to
withdraw the last minute before they're
speaking
um then they're not identified so i i
would hope that
we can have um a recommendation that um
that um people putting them forward to
speak as objectors or indeed in support
of an application actually
agree to having themselves properly
identified as to who they are
which they would have to do when they
speak in any case unless we agree to
people speaking
behind balaclavas on in a blacked out
screen
um just on the subject of the ghost
objectors at the langford bridge
application
and their the maneuvering which
prevented a proper representation
by the um the resonance group uh it's
reassuring to hear you chair now
twice in this meeting referring to the
ghost objectives as such
um it was an issue that the pas were
minded um
to label us so outrageous they couldn't
believe it would ever happen so they
didn't investigate it
but um i think it's accepted that this
is a very real risk at
a planning application discussion so the
council
um well since the issue had been raised
i i gave my views
and all i said was what i did on the day
but clearly i would hope to see that
there were steps to avoid
such a possibility arising okay i've got
um a number of other speakers still
councillor parker
thank you thank you chair um the point i
wanted to actually mention it was
something you brought up and has been
mentioned by two other councillors since
uh but i'd like to just emphasize it
again it's about town and parish
councils i believe they should actually
receive a
an invitation to speak especially now is
the case they can actually call in
um an application to committee
themselves so i do believe they should
be offered and given the opportunity
on a standard basis so i would i would
agree with that it's a good suggestion
thank you
councilman cole class
yeah that's just what i wanted to do to
support
the idea of parish and town councils
being invited to speak
uh they they represent the people at a
grassroot level they and and i think
they'd feel more involved and
would take more care and and feel more
part of the planning process so i think
that is a very good suggestion
and if if you need a proposal that
parish and town councils are ought
or are invited to speak to meetings then
i'm quite prepared to propose that
okay thank you so that's been proposed
um
is that seconded yeah it's been seconded
by councilman
mcgregor so council mcgregor you're up
next
thank you jeff um number of good points
raised i think in
in terms of i'll try and keep it as
brief as possible because i appreciate
we are going on and on here
um the the ghost uh objectives i think
perhaps what we should think about
putting in places
where where objectors wish uh not to
have anonymized um
submissions we give them priority i i
think that's important because that way
we're reducing the
risk of the system being abused
um by people um as has been implied with
the langford bridge
process and i think that's possibly a
better way to do it or
perhaps as an alternative what we do is
we say if you wish to object you have to
provide your name and address
and you can't do it anonymously because
i think it's important that we
we have an open and transparent system
and we don't allow ourselves to be
dragged
down into the kind of um
mud slinging that occurred over the the
landford bridge um
um planning application
outcome um so in in that respect you
know i'm also
um in terms of the paris and town
councils
wherever possible the the invitation to
speak to the paris and town councils
should be to their planning committee
members as opposed to their general
committee
planning committee who has already
considered it and drawn conclusions
and and you know clarified their thought
processes around the planning
application
um in terms of the the the speaking time
and the number of speakers
i think sometimes we forget that you
know our officers are
you know apparently duty-bound to to uh
help
applicants wherever possible so an
applicant is already getting
an opportunity to sell the the um
i think you made this point earlier in
yes previous on this point so
but what i was saying this is this is
coming back to a point made by the
democratic services about you know
trying to balance out the amount of time
speaking
is that they already have an element of
balance through through
um two application uh presentations
as opposed to to the objection
presentations which are
different so it was just to raise that
point as a as a
point worth noting i think thank you
councillor bullivan
thank you two quick points um firstly i
agree with the idea that the
veronic parish council town council is
the head of their planning
should have the invitation to uh partake
in a
a team bridge planning meeting secondly
in terms of selecting the number of um
speakers
the important question here is the the
points the
objectors wish to make and how many
there are if there are more than
two how are the choices made what is
their framework around which
makes that i appreciate that a general
discussion can take place to see
if there's a commonality of argument
that can be put
by one person however in many
applications there's diverse views
how do we make sure that we get a
adequate representation of those views
through the selection of the speakers
that we're going to have um
that really is basically the question
right
um so we've got the um proposal to have
parish councils invited um can i just
add to that then that we
we suggest or what do we request that um
the
speaker criteria is looked at um in
terms of
how they're identified and all the
various suggestions i mean
the suggestions of of identity and so on
um could be put into that because
clearly notes would have been taken
are you happy to include um speaker
criteria as well
council coldclough
yes i am happy yeah and and your second
i can't remember who it was
um council mcgregor okay yeah he's happy
okay so that's um that's what we're
going to be voting on a minute
councillor hook
yeah with regard to that last point not
necessarily that i
disagree with looking at the criteria
related to the speaker speakers if
there's more than two
but that could open a whole other
hornet's nest of how one speaker got
chosen above another speaker and whose
decision that was
so you know just to warn that it could
open up another hornet's nest but
you know i accept that if for example
you had three people put their name
forward and two were bad experts and one
was a member of a local residence group
you wouldn't choose the two bat experts
and ignore the person from the residence
group you'd have one of each
so you know those sort of things seem
common sensical but
just potentially it might open up
another hornet's nest of
how how speakers were chosen yeah but
we're asking for it to be considered
here not not to coming up with solutions
because clearly we're not in a position
to have all that information i don't
want to take any further comments on
that particularly
councilman mcgregor unless it's really
important well it was just to say on
that last point of counselor hooks that
um
we already have a series of subjective
decision-making processes anyway so i
don't think one more is going to add any
more difficulty into the
into the mix thank you right can we go
to the vote then please it's
as proposed by councillor kolclav that's
the um
parish council um speaker plus the
speaker criteria of others to be
considered
chris all right thank you councillor
bradford
councillor bellevant
hayes i think he's
he's still frozen at the moment i think
counselor hook oh i'm still here can you
hear me
yeah yeah
is it gone
can
anyone yeah counselor jeffrey
council mcgregor thor
councillor nuttall four
councillor nutley four councillor patch
or councillor parker
councillor hawking four
councillor goodwin bradbury four and
councillor haynes
that's unanimous chair okay thank you so
we're on to the final um one now which
is the
training joint member and officer
training we've already had council
college
speak at the outset on that issue does
anyone
i mean i can't see that there's any
anything to disagree with there
that that is considered program produced
can i just ask for
members views i've got counseling not me
please
yeah there's nothing to object to you
okay um chair um
it's just a thought in that in fact i
know we obviously
tame and parish chainsaws obviously they
they report on applications that uh
come from either team bridge or
dartmouth park um
and what my thoughts would be and i know
we've done it with the
dartmouth park officers they've actually
i mean i know in one case is going back
a little bit now but we actually had one
of the officers come from
the park to ashburton and give a
training session
on um on planning and just
uh recently dan jonatho in forward
planning
he also came and although it's virtual
um
he also gave a report it may be
something because of say
obtaining parish changes reporting on
these they're not all
um up to you know the speed that some of
our counsellors are
in in reporting on applications and
their views on applications
and i think it'd be good also to be able
to try and include
the town of paris councils in some trade
some form of training
from our officers which may be uh you
know
something to take on board in the future
thank you
councilman patch
thank you chair yeah i'm just looking at
the pas recommendations set out in the
paper
uh quite quite a short time just two
liner um
and uh we have recommended joint
training to start bridging bridging the
gap
between officers and councillors but it
might require something more proactive
and holistic
an example of which is mediation and i
think here we see that the problem of
thinking about or discussing these
issues
out of the context of the original
report
and indeed the um concerns of the full
council that led to the report being
commissioned
i mean the recommendation is talk about
bridging the gap between officers and
councillors
and mediation um so
this obviously sort of raises a number
of questions um
and what what what's the aim of this
recommendation to sort of working
towards groupthink maybe
i don't i don't know officers often have
their recommendations
and the committee sometimes goes against
them i i'm not sure that's um
an unhealthy part of um the local
democratic process
as as we see we have seen over the last
couple of years on a number of occasions
this has happened
um so i'm really not sure where this
recommendation is coming from
with its talk of bridging the gap and
mediation i thought what i wonder if so
if if you're in a position chair to sort
of spread any light on this
well it talks about mediation as being
an example
of what might be required um i think we
need to get through the initial
sort of getting together training which
has been lacking
um in recent times anyway because of the
kobe situation things like the planning
tour that i've always liked as a way in
which members and officers get together
um to sort of understand each other's
perspectives more
so i see it as being particularly that i
have previously now made an offer to
roz that i would be happy to speak to um
officers as a member to sort of give
them the chance to sort of
see inside the mind of a member and and
you know for those particularly who are
unfamiliar with it
and i'm hoping that once lockdown's over
we can get back together and do that in
a much more
um you know sort of constructive
environment than
trying to do it on on meetings such as
this one
um so i think initial training together
things like the planning tours seeing
things physically on the ground
uh would be a start uh and then we may
need to go into other
other possibilities as well as suggested
i can't see any
i mean this would have happened anyway
um
but it hasn't happened um for obvious
reasons
okay um i've
got uh councillor hook please
thank you yeah i mean i think it makes a
lot of sense i mean what that the
nature of that training obviously will
have to think about from both
perspectives of
what what we each would like the other
to know about our take on planning
and how it feels for us sort of thing um
so but it obviously makes a lot of sense
i would have thought um what i thought
as well um
yeah i recently had some planning
training where one of the
recommendations which i thought was a
good one
was some about um
some guidance about how councillors and
officers
interact before an application is
decided whether that's decided at
committee
or delegated i i think it's pretty
unclear
to maybe officers and members about how
that contact should happen
should we be emailing is it okay to
phone
um what you know are we free to discuss
it in
in any way we can we can i mean i found
out the other day that we
we actually shouldn't be asking for or
suggesting a particular decision
is made that's not within our remit um
but you know
some simple guidance like that would be
really useful i mean
we were told a while back at some
training that if you were planning
to speak against an officer
recommendation of committee you should
really be
um discussing that with them beforehand
and
so for example if you're going to
recommend refusal you could discuss the
reasons with them and i
i've tried to do that and i think that
does make sense
it doesn't always feel comfortable i
suppose because you think you're
possibly giving them a heads up on the
way you're going
but it does make a lot of sense and
that's about that team approach isn't it
to get in the best decision for the
people of team bridge in a way
um so it's it's understanding that
different approach and some guidance on
that i think
would be really useful thank you
councillor mcgregor
uh thank you i was just going to add in
i think you know that
i think training is is great i mean the
more training we get the better
i think but it would also be helpful for
um training to be extended to
parishes and towns as well to help them
with their their determination of
planning applications to enable them to
to make better decisions
whether to call in or or to to recommend
so i i think that would be helpful um
perhaps a champion
you know one you know in clusters so you
know timber town council would recommend
uh uh you know somebody from within
their group and then they would
you know put that out to dawlish bishop
stanton and and elsewhere
um so having clusters so it's not every
single town of paris council coming in
but uh certainly uh training uh extended
outwards as well
thank you yeah i think the planning cafe
format that the local plan was using
uh in the days when people could be
invited into fordhaus was a very useful
way of getting
engagement with the parish councils at
that time and i think that could be
extended once we get into planning
that's right into training um okay i
think
well nobody is sort of against training
as a concept it's just a case of
um you know sort of getting it moved
forward and um
you know sort of asking for um
a program of training to be um to be
brought forward
that we can uh we can agree to
council patch
yes yes chair thank you for your
previous answer i just wanted to just
raise this issue once more of this issue
of bridging the gap
between officers and councillors um sort
of in the context of maybe there are
concerns
um sort of perhaps at a senior level
within team bridge that planning
of um committee members need to be
brought into line somehow
and i i think it's healthy to have um
disagreements between the views of
officers on a particular recommendation
and the view that the
um this committee might take yeah i
wouldn't see it as bringing
members into line i would simply see it
as being making sure that members were
fully aware
of their responsibilities under the
planning legislation
um so you know that's so that members
are making
objective decisions under that
framework okay so i would suggest that
we just ask here that um
that roz produces a
proposed um training program perhaps in
consultation with myself and the vice
chairman and this is
um brought forward as soon as possible
in the
and the covered circumstances i mean if
we have to do it virtually again and i
think we have done we have done training
virtually
since the start of this there has been i
don't know at least of one occasion
and it would have to be so but hopefully
in in physical
uh presence so can i propose that that
is the case that we asked where i was in
consultation with
the vice chairman and myself bring that
forward counseling that this second did
that
um we better have a vote on this one as
well please so
chris please
thank you chair um counselor bradford
that's obelivent councillor clarence
paul councillor colclough oh
that's a haze
i think he's still gone at the moment
counselor jeffrey
no um counselor mcgregor
four i know notice councillor hayes is
back as well
yeah okay um
counselor hayes can you speak at the
moment
[Music]
yeah um now come back
okay can you hear me at all yeah yeah
four okay okay
[Music]
yeah counseling uh strongly for
councillor nutley
council patch
councillor parker or councillor hawking
or counselor goodman bradbury
and councillor haynes
that's unanimous chair thank you so that
concludes the items that we were giving
our
views on so those can be taken forward
thank you for that
if we can move on into the final item on
the agenda which is the
item eight appeal decisions to be noted
anything to comment on there rise or not
uh no not really i mean i i was
reflecting after our uh
um catch up on this yesterday about the
the couple of um
appeals allowed uh where there were
delegated refusals
and and uh i think
at least one of those is a design
led refusal so we didn't think that the
scheme that come forward was good enough
but the inspectorate um
disagreed with us and reached a
different conclusion um and
we've had a uh that outcome elsewhere as
well recently one of the the things that
is on
at the back of my mind for member
training
is to have a session on design and on
um the difference between uh
my view of the government rhetoric
around design and then the actual
support that we get from the planning
inspectorate when we try and make um
decisions uh to refuse schemes based on
on what we consider to be poor design so
and
and the the impact or lack thereof that
the
government's design code and the
building better uh commission outcomes
seem to be having on that so
um where we tr it's it's disappointing
uh to see that
um but apart from that the the decisions
on the whole um
uh yeah were largely as expected i think
this time
yeah obviously there is a lot on design
on the government's um agenda at the
moment i think the new
head of planning at um ministry of
housing etc
is uh from a design background so that's
that's an interesting thing to watch it
develop
uh council mcgregor uh thank you chair
it was just uh
to know that there was uh a couple of
non-determinations in there
um i haven't looked at whether they were
approved or not
but it was just to query i know that i
noticed that there's a few on the
the um planning portal that are beyond
their their
uh time for decision as well and i just
want wanted to know whether
that was down to resource within the
department uh
new staff coming in briny you know
bright shiny new
planning officers maybe not quite
getting up to speed yet that sort of
thing
so really to kind of try and understand
on the on the non-determination side
rosita well it is relatively um it was
covered in um
the presentation that councillor taylor
gave to overview in scrutiny 2 last week
and so those slides i think came out to
all members
um afterwards in the members newsletter
um but we have had a an element of a
perfect storm this year with um
a turnover of staff um uh
the impact in general of uh kovid
um on the workforce including some and
staff absence and you know illnesses and
sickness
we have also as a consequence of the way
that covert impacted on the
um property market has a
change in the pattern of applications
that have come in and this is something
that's being seen by our neighbours as
well
um you know where we would normally get
uh roughly
20 or 25 applications through the door a
week we've had several weeks where we've
had 40 applications coming through the
door so
there's been a real shift in the way
that the work's been coming in
so we have extremely high workloads at
the moment and the team are working
incredibly hard to get the
through the workload um but we do have a
backlog that
is quite high at the moment we are
working really hard to try and get that
down
um but as a consequence if that some of
our customers are exercising their right
to submit non-determination appeals so
they then uh have the
uh we then if once the appeal has been
submitted we can't make a decision on it
uh and it's with pins to determine um
it's a uh as a gamble
i guess whether you think you're gonna
get a decision more quickly from pins or
from us but if you had
uh one of the applications on that list
i think there was a
a concern or a doubt that we weren't
going to support it so they thought
they'd get the appeal in
um you know there was no point in
waiting until we'd finished making our
decision that's the the one in the north
of the district the business used one
so there there are um complex
reasons multi-faceted reasons why uh
we have a you know a lot of work and a
backlog at the moment which is leading
to an increase
in non-determination appeals okay thank
you
right well that then concludes today's
meeting thank you all very much
for your attendance and i look forward
to seeing you all
soon uh so that's it feel free to log
off
thank you chair all right thank you mike
thanks thank you mike